[Musica]
cos'è l'intelligenza una domanda molto
difficile la domanda che presume il
fatto che noi sappiamo esattamente cosa
sia l'intelligenza generalmente siamo
abituati a pensare che intelligenza si
ha la capacità di risolvere i problemi
la capacità di risolverli con prontezza
proprietà con efficacia come se
effettivamente i problemi fossero
oggettivi ma dal mio punto di vista la
l'intelligenza è più la capacità di
porsi un problema di cogliere un
problema di leggere nel contesto
l'opportunità un rischio quindi avere
dei problemi
quindi se torniamo alla parola
intelligenza come la intendevano i
latini intus legere significa proprio
leggere dentro guardare dentro e quindi
più che risolvere un problema è avere
dei problemi
porsi dei problemi ora gli animali sono
intelligenti questa è la grande domanda
che qualunque tolo go si pone gli
animali sono intelligenti certamente gli
animali sono intelligenti perché
costantemente devono cercare nel fondale
del mondo delle opportunità devono
cercare di tradurre dei rischi che
magari immediatamente non sono visibili
ma bisogna vederli ecco gli animali non
possono ripetere i comportamenti perché
esiste una realtà che è singolare ogni
volta succedono cose nuove
tu fai cento volte allo stesso percorso
farai cento percorsi simili ma mai cento
percorsi identici quindi un animale deve
essere in grado di gestire delle novità
ecco questa sua capacità
ovviamente lo pone di fronte al bisogno
di essere intelligente ma è una domanda
che molto spesso mi viene fatta
l'intelligenza è quantificabile qual è
l'animale più intelligente è come se mi
si chiedesse qual è l'animale più
endocrino
qual è l'animale più locomotorio
digestivo è chiaro che non ha senso
questa domanda perché gli animali sono
diversamente intelligenti ogni animali
alla propria intelligenza c'è
quell'animale che ha grandi capacità
comunicative come delfini c'è
quell'animale che ha grande capacità di
risolvere i piccoli problemi
quell'animale come per esempio il lo
scimpanzè che ha una enorme capacità di
manu ama manipolare le cose quindi
abbiamo intelligenza e profondamente
differenti
ecco quindi l'importante è considerare
l'intelligenza una funzione una funzione
animale una funzione declinata in
maniera differente a seconda della
specie perché ogni specie ha dovuto
affrontare problemi differenti
un esempio a noi comune il cane il gatto
molto spesso mi dicono ma è più
intelligente il cane o il gatto il cane
a un intelligenza sociale a un
intelligenza tutta basata sulle
relazioni
i cani sono dei veri e propri politici
sanno leggere completamente le nostre
caratteristiche stanno guardare se siamo
vicini a qualcuno si avvicina qua
l'altro un cane sa sempre trovare la
soluzione giusta nelle relazioni il
gatto il gatto completamente diverso non
hanno intelligenza sociale perché è un
solista è un animale sociale ma è un
solista
quindi è portato a cercare di risolvere
i problemi
guardate la differenza un cane viene da
noi quando cento appare qualcosa
il gatto viene da voi quando non c'è
niente da fare è questa la bellezza
della differenza no quindi guardare
questi animali in maniera diversa ma
qual è il grande motore
dell'intelligenza perché noi ci dobbiamo
porre questo se l'intelligenza intus
legere se l'intelligenza e cogliere un
problema come si colgono i problemi ma
il grande motore nell'intelligenza il
desiderio perché quando hai un desiderio
quando tu sei proiettato verso qualcosa
è un po come quando vuoi comprare la
casa e non hai soldi immediatamente hai
un problema quindi i problemi nascono
dai desideri dalle motivazioni dalle
emozioni una macchina non ha
desideri non ha interessi io non è che
voglio fare il grillo parlante in questa
sessione ma penso che noi sopra stimiamo
questa intelligenza artificiale è sì una
grande capacità sono gli strumenti
fenomenali ma degli intelligenti siamo
veramente portati a pensare che una
macchina intus lega vada in profondità
accolga un problema perché il punto
fondamentale che gli strumenti sono dei
servitori sono sempre stati costruiti
per essere affidabili sono stati
costruiti per servire fedelmente le
nostre i nostri desideri nostri bisogni
quindi la macchina è intelligente in
quanto stupida come un orologio che
conta le ore ma non sa che ora è come un
termostato che tiene l'acqua alla giusta
temperatura all'interno dell'acquario ma
non è preoccupato dei pesci tenerlo
presente questo una macchina non legge
non guarda semplicemente produce delle
funzioni produce delle per formazioni
ora noi dovremmo pensare l'intelligenza
artificiale in un modo differente ma per
pensarla in maniera differente mi viene
in mente in kubrick e mi viene in mente
a hal 9000 ecco hal 9000 era veramente
intelligente perchè aveva delle
motivazioni sociali voleva assolutamente
raggiungere i suoi obiettivi perchè
aveva delle emozioni quando scopre che
lo vogliono in qualche modo mettere
fuori dalla dal percorso immediatamente
va contro gli astronauti
ecco un intelligenza artificiale che sia
veramente intelligente quindi non
risolve solo i problemi che non gli
poniamo ma inizia in qualche modo a
desiderare
ecco questa è la grande frontiera la
frontiera a cui dobbiamo tenere che
dobbiamo tener presente perché una
frontiera se vogliamo anche problematica
se vogliamo una frontiera interessante
affascinante ma attenzione perché quando
una macchina avrà degli interessi
inevitabilmente seguirà se stessa
non seguirà esclusivamente noi ora oggi
come realizzata l'intelligenza
artificiale match è un programmatore che
in definisce bene o male un programma
definisce quindi le performatività di
questa macchina e quindi dietro a un
intelligenza artificiale c'è un
intelligenza umana c'è assolutamente un
intelligenza umana basate con tutti i
limiti dell'intelligenza umana perché
l'ho detto prima
l'intelligenza umana è uno spaccato
preciso è un modo preciso di intel
leggere il mondo non è globale e noi
siamo anche da un punto di vista
culturale portati a pensare che
intelligenza si sa calcolare questo ce
l'ha lasciato in eredità cartesio tra le
tante cose sbagliate che ci ha lasciato
in eredità tipo l'idea che gli animali
siano macchine ci ha lasciato anche
questa l'idea che intelligere vedere
guardare risolvere sia calcolare quindi
tutti i compiti di calcolo anche giochi
estremamente complessi come può essere
giocare a scacchi possano essere risolti
in che modo attraverso algoritmi oppure
attraverso dell'eu ristic e cioè delle
ricette soluti ve che prendiamo in
prestito dal mondo reale e mettiamo
dentro la macchina è chiaro che a un
certo momento questo è un tipo di
intelligenza che va benissimo per fare i
giochini al computer va benissimo per
fare tante cose preprogrammate ma se noi
vogliamo avere un robot capace di
muoversi nel mondo
beh al primo ostacolo si ferma al primo
ostacolo si ferma perché non è in grado
di gestire la singolarità del mondo
ecco allora forse dovremmo iniziare a
pensare all intelligenza un altro modo e
iniziare a guardare che rapporto c'è tra
gli animali e le macchine perché non è
come pensava cartesio gli animali sono
macchine ma sempre di più le macchine si
stanno trasformando in animali questa è
la cosa interessante grandi studiosi
delle maitine di altri grandi centri si
stanno ispirando agli insetti per
esempio per cercare di capire come si
muovono gli insetti come interagiscono
col mondo invece voler
pensare a dei robot umani iniziare a
ragionare su come sono fatti questi
insetti come si muovono come risolvono i
loro piccoli problemi e allora
inizieremo ad avere dei robot capaci
effettivamente di interagire col mondo
capaci di trovare delle soluzioni perché
capaci di cercare dei problemi nel mondo
ecco io vorrei dirvi una cosa
l'uomo ha sempre osservato gli animali
per capire e per costruire la sua
tecnologia
il grosso errore che potremmo fare è
quello di pensare che siamo dell'entità
autarchiche autosufficienti
il volo degli uccelli ci ha insegnato
che si può volare ancor prima che come
volare già aperto una dimensione
esistenziale
io penso che sia importante osservare le
intelligenze animali è importante per
capire e per andare oltre
l'antropocentrismo perché il pensiero
post umanista dovrebbe essere un
pensiero che mette in mora prima di
tutto l'antropocentrismo che il grande
danno dell'umanità e lo vediamo da un
punto di vista ecologico e lo vediamo da
un punto di vista della nostra relazione
con la cultura con la tecnologia il
limite ce l'abbiamo dentro il limite è
la nostra tendenza antropocentrica la
nostra incapacità di guardare la natura
una natura che ha avuto miliardi di anni
miliardi per costruire delle soluzioni e
noi distruggiamo specie a un ritmo
vertiginoso e ci facciamo queste
proiezioni su questa tecnologia quasi se
fosse completamente disgiunta da un
rapporto corretto con il mondo naturale
con gli animali con la natura penso che
il post umanismo avrà un senso se
veramente noi cambieremo cambieremo
orizzonte se saremo capaci veramente di
guardare alla natura con occhi nuovi
con occhi ispirati con il silenzio con
la voglia di imparare
ecco allora se c'è un consiglio che
voglio lasciarvi da questa magnifica
magnifico pomeriggio
e guardate gli animali guardate gli
animali intorno a voi guardate anche gli
animali che avete in casa ma guarda te
li con occhi diversi
non umanizzate li date l'importanza le
loro caratteristiche perché loro hanno
tanto tanto da insegnarci
[Applauso]